[Music]
But hey, so even if you have a trained dog effect, it's dangerous if you decide even for a moment.
-The goal has appeared It
's
okay The strong-looking guy lurking in this cave is just a little further up the track
I don't want to feel like I'm binging I ca
n't do anything me
ah ah ah
It's hot on the run My magical power is draining faster than I imagined
Jami It's dangerous to stay here any longer
Hurry up and taste unknown ingredients and say 50 types of magical power
But from a while ago  I ca
n't get anything, I don't think it's here I can
feel the signs of unknown ingredients, etc.,
but ran the ingredients, etc. I was frightened by something.
It's okay to live on the
3rd floor
[music]
is good It's
the 8th Clock Kaifu-gun Thank you dare ni I think you were trying
rar It looks like it's
cold
We've finally opened up here We
're just doing that  1
[music]
Then you can see the face of this market,
this guy's dokkubi campaign